sein du détournement du dc9 du der ya
les trois pirates se sont rendus à
genève un an après la mort de paul vi ce
qui a changé au vatican avec jean paul
goude tauromachie el cordobès les
revenus hier ils adorent et à bayonne
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir il y a un
an mort et le pape paul vi il avait
occupé le trône de saint pierre pendant
15 ans ayant été élu comme successeur de
jean xxiii
son oeuvre est considérable entre autres
c'est lui qui commencent à appliquer les
décisions du concile vatican 2 ce
prodigieux rassemblement qui en trois
ans de travaux avait changé dans tous
les domaines de visage et sans doute
l'avenir de l'église catholique paul si
c'était un homme de réflexion mais de
rigueur tout en nuances nez plein
d'énergie n'hésitant pas à tracer sur la
petite planète où nous vivons notre
existence terrestre des itinéraires
plein de symboles comme le dit jean
guitton qui l'a bien connu
c'était un gros sauts basques et à sa
mort les cardinaux s'assemblèrent tu as
rome ou un premier conclave lui et lui
comme successeur le patriarche de venise
le cardinal lucia née qui prit le nom de
jean paul 1er se jetant à corps perdu
dans la tâche et il succomba en moins de
deux mois alors les cardinaux se réunir
une nouvelle fois en conclave est à 8
tours de scrutin il sait lire pour la
première fois depuis un demi millénaire
un pape étrangers un polonais
l'archevêque de cracovie karol wojtyla
qui prennent le nom de jean paul ii et
dont la route stature l'aspect
athlétique joints sont l'état de
polonais frappèrent terriblement la
catholicité la chrétienté et le monde
presque entier hier jean paul ii par
leur 2.6 disait ce grand pape a donné à
l'église et au monde son message ultime
qui est d'amour d'humilité et de don de
soi
jean paul ii a également fait une
déclaration aux envoyés spéciaux
d'antenne 2 un reportage de jean claude
d'arrigo
footing bénédiction et un temps pour
l'église il a été le pasteur des
consciences avec l'humilité et fermeté
ce poisson espérances lyon perd une de
regarder et de préparer l'avenir
recommandons son âme aux crises de la
transfiguration
plus gênant dans les soins
non
une foule bigarrée au rendez vous pour
cette semaine anniversaire de la mort de
paul 6 une semaine que jean paul ii a
voulu à l'évidence marqué d'une manière
particulière aussi bien au vatican qu'à
castelgandolfo je suis le continuateur
de paul s'ils s'affirment en toutes
circonstances le pape polonais et cela
est parfaitement vrai sur le plan de la
doctrine
cependant il y à ce style particulier de
jean paul ii un style qui le rend déjà
unique en son genre
un exemple parmi d'autres il a
transformé le palais d'été des papes en
une espèce de résidences secondaires où
il entend se reposer tranquillement
comme tout un chacun
ouvrant ses portes alternativement aux
pèlerins ou à des petits groupes avec
desquels il veut s'entretenir en liberté
le pape est aussi une personne privée a
dit récemment jean paul ii une
affirmation qui a surpris par sa
normalité
le pape l homme comme tout le monde
pourtant les vacances pour jean paul ii
ne signifie pas la mise entre
parenthèses des problèmes de la planète
chaque jour on lui apporte des dossiers
parmi ceux ci un drame celui des
réfugiés du sud est asiatique
il a voulu en recevoir une centaine
personnellement en audience privée pour
la première fois notre équipe fut admise
à lui poser quelques questions à faire
de notre pays un prêt ni beaucoup
d'envié de mieux chez bic est ce qu'on
pensait que la communauté qu'elle
devrait faire encore mieux à faire tous
les possibles que sont possibles et je
pense qu'il faut toujours élargir les
mesures de la charité c'est un simple
fait où les mesures de la charité
doivent durable encore à l'affronter
s'adresse que c'est un sujet que vous
évoquerez durant votre voyage aux
etats-unis particulièrement ce problème
des réfugiés
on y aller
mercredi 18h sur la place saint-pierre
le moment de l'audience publique jean
paul ii a quitté castel gandolfo depuis
un quart d'heure dans l'hélicoptère qui
utilisent de plus en plus fréquemment
pour lui l'important est le contact avec
les personnes en a murmuré qu'il ne
lésinait pas sur les moyens
la foule elle retient son sourire le mot
qu'il sait dire cette chaleur humaine
qui émane de lui etes-vous chrétien je
demandais en anglais à un groupe de
japonais non non il répondu mais cet
homme est extraordinaire il appartient à
tous
jean paul ii au grand désespoir de
certains au vatican bouscule
régulièrement tout protocole il nous
tuera murmurait il ya peu de temps un
prêt l'un des palets pontificaux avec le
nouveau pape l'imagination
l'improvisation sont résolument au
pouvoir il a même le courage de ces
nostalgies on le voit régulièrement
reprendre des cantiques de sa pologne
natale marquantes ostensiblement le
rythme
une version la tête avec émotion
et puis il ya ces gestes qui ne trompent
pas ces enfants embrasser ces malades
écoutez les yeux dans les yeux ces
groupes de jeunes mis en relief comme
espoir de l'église toutes ces
manifestations à travers lesquels jean
paul ii n'a pas peur de se montrer tel
qu'il est un homme sensible qui porte
sur les épaules la responsabilité la
plus écrasante du monde celle de 850
millions de personnes 850 millions de
personnes sans compter toutes les autres
celle qui sans être catholique savent
reconnaître dans le pape actuel
l'une des personnalités les plus aptes à
défendre vraiment les droits de la
personne humaine
à
selon monseigneur lefebvre ça marche
avec de dakar et chef de file des
catholiques traditionalistes ses
relations avec le vatican s'améliore
sensiblement sa récente entrevue avec le
pape jean paul ii a été dit il bénéfique
et il ne se sent plus persécutée je cite
comme du temps de pause 6 et du cardinal
ville dans les alpes maritimes va
continuer à lutter contre le feu les
canadairs ont été à nouveau mise en
oeuvre notamment dans la région de
roquebillière sur des sommets très
abrupte et qu'on ne peut atteindre
autrement
mais les incendies sont éteints dans les
régions de lantosque de la brigue et de
pierrefeu au total malheureusement en
une semaine c'est plus d'un millier
d'hectares qui ont été détruits par les
flammes le week-end sur les routes
il y a eu moins de morts que week-end
précédent 57 au lieu de 70 mais le
nombre de blessés est plus élevée
presque 800 dont 225 grièvement touchés
détournement d'avion hors série ce matin
aux îles canaries il s'agit d' un dc9 de
la compagnie espagnole iberia
les pirates de l'air trois hommes dont
deux français avaient pour but affirmé
t-il d'échapper à la légion étrangère
espagnole
il voulait chercher refuge en france on
leur a refusé l'atterrissage
finalement après mêmes péripéties ils se
sont posés en suisse il n'y a pas eu
fort heureusement de victimes cet après
midi que trois légionnaires dont deux
français en relais dans la bande des
rares la légion étrangère espagnole
détourne un dc9 de la compagnie iberia
ils bloquent à l'intérieur de l'appareil
23 passagers l'équipage et deux employés
du service de nettoyage leur armement
est impressionnant deux fusils
mitrailleurs et 79 cartouches
j'ai recommandations du pilote la
manière forte ne sera pas utilisé
plusieurs destinations sont envisagées
alger le maroc la rhodésie et enfin la
france qui refuse de droits
d'atterrissage sur l'ensemble de ses
aéroports
ils répondent par la négative aux
propositions portugaise d'évacuer
l'avion en échange de la promesse de
n'être pas extradé en espagne
les trois hommes après avoir demandé de
la nourriture et du kérosène grandes
écoles pour la suisse non sans avoir
libéré six passagers dont tous les
enfants
le gouvernement helvétique n'accepte
l'atterrissage à genève que contre
l'assurance que les trois hommes se
rendront à la police à 16 heures 15
heure de genève l'appareil de la
compagnie iberia ce beau sur l'aéroport
la suisse autorise en habituellement
l'atterrissage des avions détournés
qu'elle assimile à des avions en
difficulté très vite les auteurs du
détournement descente de l'avion les six
derniers otages sont libres quatre cent
mille chinois prêté à l'italie une
nouvelle surprenante venus de pékin
en fait l'aboutissement d'un accord
réalisé entre l'institut vers
construction industriels italiens et les
chinois
il porte sur le départ vers l'étranger
un départ échelonné sur cinq ans de 400
mille travailleurs chinois hautement
spécialisés ils travailleront dans les
pays du tiers-monde et l'exclusion des
pays du bloc soviétique pour essayer
d'être un peu clair dans cette affaire
il faut ajouter qu'une récente loi
promulguée pékin permet la création
d'entreprises chinoises travaillant à
l'étranger
mais bien évidemment en se servant d'une
main d'oeuvre chinoise alors que vont
ils faire ces chinois essentiellement
des travaux de construction de grosses
construction chemin de fer épouse est
une aide
c'est une nouvelle importante qui
demandera dans les jours qui viennent
une analyse sérieuse en exportant sa
main d'oeuvre
la chine fait un premier pas dans une
direction jusqu'ici inconnu pour elle
sans doute qui est belle brune pas
repoussé par le chômage mais la décision
d'aujourd'hui peut certainement
déboucher sur des mesures très
importantes dans l'avenir une question
en tout cas à suivre de très près à un
accord présenté comme étant de paix
définitive a été signé hier à alger
entre la mauritanie et le front
polisario
l'accord stipule que la mauritanie n'a
plus de revendications territoriales sur
le sahara occidental au maroc on affirme
que c'est une véritable capitulation de
la mauritanie qui se produit malgré les
mises en garde récente est très ferme du
roy assad
le maroc a l'impression d'être comme
l'on dit en langage militaire tourné par
le sud
et donc ce n'est pas cet accord qui peut
contribuer à ramener la paix dans cette
région l'on se bat depuis quatre ans
philippe châtelain
il a suffi de trois jours de
négociations entre mauritaniens et
sahraoui dans cette villa d'alger pour
parvenir à un accord de paix la
mauritanie réaffirme sa détermination de
sortir définitivement de ce qu'elle
appelle désormais la guerre injuste du
sahara occidental
deuxième point important la mauritanie
reconnaît formellement le front
polisario ainsi que les droits nationaux
du peuple sahraoui
enfin des mauritaniens renonce aux
termes de cet accord à toutes leurs
revendications territoriales sur le
savent sans doute pour éviter de
provoquer une réaction encore plus vive
de la part du maroc
l'accord évite soigneusement de préciser
les modalités précises selon lesquelles
ce fort à l'évacuation par les
mauritaniens de leur partie du sahara
occidental
la guinée équatoriale a été le théâtre
hier d'une révolution qui a abattu le
terrible régime instauré par monsieur
francisco macias nguema
rappelons que ce territoire appartenait
à l'espagne jusqu'en 1968 et ce site
avait alors à croyez sans aucune
effusion de sang
l'indépendance à ce qui sape la depuis
la guinée équatoriale les commentaires
de bernard à la guinée équatoriale est
cité entre le cameroun et le gabon
peuplée de 4 familles habitant ce pays
avait à la veille de son indépendance
l'un des revenus les plus élevés
d'afrique
mais l'économie guinéenne n'a cessé de
décliner depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir de
francisco macias nguema président à vie
l'épousé endiguer maquis se qualifiait
lui-même d'unique miracle de la guinée
et que l'on voit ici lors de sa prise de
fonction le voici restera l'un des
tyrans les plus sanguinaires de
l'histoire du continent africain ses
victimes se comptent par milliers
essentiellement des opposants ou juger
tel mais aussi comme en 1969 des
européens dès cette époque racketter par
la milice personnelle du président le
pays a commencé à se dépeupler le
n'estime dix ans plus tard que la
population de guinée équatoriale a
diminué de moitié
la cote du président carter commencerait
elle à remonter monsieur white président
du comité national du parti démocrate
c'est à dire le propre parti du
président des états unis s'est déclaré
persuadé aujourd'hui comme ceux carter
serais tu anovo choisi comme le candidat
démocrate aux élections présidentielles
de l'an prochain de plus monsieur white
et c'est important
affirmant qu'à son avis
le sénateur edward kennedy dont on parle
beaucoup ne sera pas candidat le
président sadate peu organisée le 19
novembre un festival pour célébrer le
deuxième anniversaire de son fameux
voyage à jérusalem est ce pour montrer
la réconciliation entre israélite
musulmans et chrétiens pour affirmer la
paix entre juifs et arabes
il y aura une cérémonie religieuse au
coeur du sinaï est un festival
artistique au caire le président sadate
boutin s'est associé au sinaï le monde
entier à la pose de la première pierre
d'un ensemble comprenant une mosquée une
synagogue une église copte à la fête
artistique qu'elle sera organisé par
roger vadim que monsieur sa date vient
de recevoir longuement au nicaragua le
nouveau régime s'installe il veut le
faire dans la paix retrouvée et autant
que possible dans la sérénité
trois semaines après la chute de somoza
ce sont les jeunes guérilleros ce les
muchachos qui règlent la circulation
mais le fusil en bandoulière rappelle
qu'il y a tout juste un mois on se
battait dans cette rue problème numéro 1
des nicaraguayens le ravitaillement
sans doute les marchands qu'il fait leur
réapparition mais le pays manque de tout
l'aide américaine est par exemple très
inférieurs selon la junte à ce qui avait
été promis
autre souci des autorités empêché les
fidèles de l'ancien régime de quitter le
pays on redoute que des groupes contre
révolutionnaires ne s'organise à
l'étranger aussi les contrôles sont ils
prêts stricte dans les aéroports
ce journal appartenait à somoza et cet
homme qui le déchirent sous nos yeux en
est le nouveau directeur
aujourd'hui le journal a changé de titre
qui s'appelle maintenant barricades à la
barricade et son nouveau directeur
explique que c'est maintenant le journal
du peuple nicaraguayen et c'est vrai de
craindre peut-être que quelques
commandes aux contre révolutionnaires ne
détruisent les rotatives
le peuple est là qui veille
la radio sandiniste s'est quant à elle
installée dans les anciens locaux de la
radio somoziste mais là encore le
message a changé aujourd'hui dit le
commentateur le peuple de non à
l'impérialisme yankee les soldats de la
garde nationale la guardia ce de triste
mémoire continue à être recherché mais
il n'y a pas eu jusqu'ici d'exactions et
la peine de mort a été abolie
un miracle si l'on se souvient des
atrocités commises par les guardia ces
mois derniers
de nombreux soldats de l'ancien régime
avait trouvé refuge dans ce centre de la
croix rouge ou leurs familles venaient
les ravitailler chaque jour mais un
récent contrôle a montré que malgré la
vigilance des délégués du cicr des armes
avaient été introduites et cachés dans
le centre les nouvelles autorités de
managua ont donc décidé de vider le
centre et de transférer les guardian un
millier environ à la prison de modelo
dans la banlieue de managua
ouais
c'est dans cette prison que les guardian
attendront ceux du moins qui sont
accusés de crimes essentiellement des
officiers des sous-officiers
c'est là qu'ils attendront de passer en
jugement monsieur georges lâcher a
critiqué une fois de plus et faire
violemment la politique gouvernementale
il l'a dit au micro de rtl
le chômage et l'austérité sont le
résultat d'une politique délibérée c'est
le gouvernement de monsieur giscard
d'estaing et raymond barre qui organise
la hausse des prix en déclenchant un
ouragan de hausse le pétrole n'est pas
responsable du chômage et de l'inflation
il a ajouté en substance le gouvernement
ne supporte pas les critiques
je propose un débat télévisé qui
passionne près des français et où je me
trouverai en face de monsieur raymond
barre
à 21h40 notre émission question de temps
vous parlera de la france c'est la
dernière des six émissions de la série
quelle france dont le but est de vous
faire mieux aimer des régions de la
france actuelle et parfois même de vous
les faire découvrir ce soir donc est
présenté par jean-pierre elkabbach la
dernière émission de la série climat de
gironde un programme préparé par
philippe gildas nicklès eric louer qui
en jetait sur les grandes régions
françaises
un regard honnête un regard chaleureux
après les roues les pyrénées atlantiques
l'aisne le nord la haute loire ce soir à
21h40 ne manquez pas question de temps
j'ajoute que jean pierre elkabbach et
louis berio organiserons ensuite à peu
près à la rentrée à l'occasion d'un
samedi et demi un débat général avec des
représentants des régions que les
missions vous aura montré chaque année
plus d'une dizaine de millions de
français choisissent pour passer
quelques semaines au bord de la mer ou à
la montagne la toile de tente où la
caravane
cette année les français ont été plus
nombreux que jamais à prendre ainsi
leurs vacances dans les campings et cela
en plus du plaisir de le faire bien
entendu pour des raisons évidentes
d'économies mais l'une des conséquences
de la plus grand père par exemple sur
nos côtes
c'est une série d'entassement étonnant
aux alentours des corps notamment dans
le midi jean jacques dufour qui n'a peur
de rien s'est rendu à saint-aygulf dans
le bar pour visiter un camping dont le
moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que les
gens n'y sont pas tout à fait à leur
aise
qu'on suit normalement pour 3500
personnes
ce camping de sainte et gül accueille en
ce moment 4200 personnes de façon
réglementaire puisque la surcharge
toléré et de 20% au-dessus de la
capacité d'accueil une surcharge qui
serait bien plus grande si on accepte et
tous ceux qui désirent 100 mètres carrés
maximum de vacances qu'est ce qui se
passe là faut c'est des gens qu'ils
obtiennent le pourront ils se font
inscrire viennent aujourd'hui rentrant
aujourd'hui ou demain ou après-demain
énormément de monde là je deviens trop
trop de monde
l'incroyable s'est produit en juin cause
de
comment d'espagne de france et de
l'étranger de tous qu on ne veut plus du
monde
puis samedi qu'il a eue samedi sept
personnes
monsieur lui là depuis samedi et attend
et on appelait en 100 kg alors
maintenant on est ici on va attendre
venez d'où le cambrai du nord c'est pour
ça qu'on attend je voulais faire du
rodéo la vie des étrangers s'il vous
plais larionov ce qu'ils ont paré ou
qu'est ce qu'ils en pensent ils savent
parler français je suis là depuis
vendredi soir et on en est encore là et
vous pouvez pas démonté une toile de
tente sur le bord de l'eau les gosses
dans les autos mais les vendredis soirs
et mer sur les trottoirs c'est dommage
qu'il ait pas plus chaud sur les plages
du nord sans quoi il y aurait pas tarder
genre dans le midi ainsi partout dans
les vingt-quatre camp de la ville qui
permettent normalement d'accueillir 20
mille vacanciers on affiche complet
il y a environ en france 7 millions de
pratiquants du camping caravaning pour 1
million 700 mille places qui peuvent les
recevoir
nous demandons dans l'immédiat ce que le
budget qui était prévu par la jeunesse
et des sports
c'est à dire 150 mille places par an
puisse être fier alors que rien n'a été
fait jusqu'à ce jour et nous demandons
ensuite le doublement des places de
camping dans les cinq ans qui viennent
pour cela
tourisme et travail organise une
campagne d'information sur une dizaine
de jours qui va traverser la provence
côte d'azur pour dénoncer disons
l'entassement et aussi la libération des
prix il faut dire aussi que la
sursaturation du littoral est un
phénomène de société
car si tout est complet en bord de mer
il reste des places à l'intérieur des
terres mais voilà les vacances à la mer
doivent être des vacances à proximité de
la plage par commodité explique les
campeurs mais aussi par économie une
fois sur place on préfère toucher le
moins possible à la voiture le prix de
l'essence et les encombrements de la
circulation sont des freins puissants un
camping dans l'arrière pays ont fait de
la route sans arrêt pendant 11 mois dans
l'année c'est pas encore de la route
après quand on est en vacances
ou plus si c'est pour me baigner c'est
pas pour aller voir ce qui se passe
autour de moi j'y mets pas passer pour
eux c'est comme ça c'est pour aller me
baigner attentes embaucher alors on vit
plus ou moins sur les autres on dort
parfois trois jours dans une voiture
comme cette dame mais on accepte bien
cette promiscuité lt partie de
l'ambiance
une ambiance qu'on aime retrouver
puisque certains comme jean albert
creusot qui a déjà usé trois tentes et
quatre caravanes revient depuis 21 ans
au même endroit
j'ai l'argent mais sans mais bon c'est
le cas de tout le monde la chaire
tellement le cas tout le monde sauf sauf
peut-être des gens qui venaient ensemble
qui ce groupe n'est ce pas par exemple
j'avais par la fis les cousins du hacker
le groupe et notre monde et c'est
inhumain on a de la place ici vous allez
faire un partage ici regardez les gens
où j'avais des trois mécontents mais
vous savez les français sont alors les
déchets de paille
alors pour contenter tout le monde c'est
très difficile
c'est d'autant plus difficile que la
capacité globale d'accueil est inférieur
de moitié aux besoins et que sur le
littoral les terrains de camping en bord
de mer sont relativement restreint
souvent on préfère occuper ces surfaces
à d'autres fins la coupe d'europe
d'athlétisme est un très grand événement
sportif disputé à turin en italie
elle a marqué la supériorité des
athlètes hommes et dames de l'allemande
de l'est marita koch par exemple a
amélioré son record du monde du 400
mètres dans le temps exceptionnel de 48
secondes et 60 centièmes
les français n'ont pas été brillant
brillant bien que vermeer l'amitié quel
joli nom ma part apaise et gagner le
triple saut battant le record de france
abad a été deuxième à la perche sinon
nous avons été assez souvent 5e 6e 7e 8e
un an avant les jeux olympiques de
moscou on peut se poser des questions
thierry roland a commenté ce week end
les épreuves en direct
il en reprend les moments essentiels
les finales des coupes d'europe
d'athlétisme disputée le week-end
dernier à turin et remportée chez les
hommes comme chez les femmes par les
athlètes de la rda ont été d'un niveau
rarement atteint puisque plus de vingt
records nationaux ont été battus de même
qu'un record d'europe et deux records du
monde sur 800 m le fantastique
britannique sebastian coe nouvelle
vedette du demi fond mondial s'impose à
de toute une classe
sur sa forme actuelle il sera difficile
à battre dans un an à l'occasion des
jeux olympiques de moscou
l'autre vedette masculine de la
compétition
puis un jeune allemand de 22 ans harald
schmidt
il commence sa part battre à l'occasion
du 400 m haies est l'un des plus vieux
record d'europe en 47 secondes 85
centièmes améliorant de 27 centièmes de
seconde la performance qui avait fait du
britannique david henrie un surprenant
champion olympique à mexico en 1968 il
ya déjà 11 moins de 60 minutes plus tard
il enlevait le 400 m plat en 45 secondes
tremper une avant de compléter le
lendemain la victoire de son équipe dans
le relais 4 x 400 m soit 24 points à lui
tout seul
quant aux français dans un tel contexte
ils ont fait ce qu'ils ont pu à une
triste première journée a succédé un
deuxième jour plus conforme à la valeur
de l'athlétisme français bernard
l'amitié ce n'est pas lui
remportant le triple saut avec un bond
de 16 m 94 nouveau record de france les
sauts reste une bonne spécialité
nationale puisque l'an passé à prague
jacques rousseau enlevait le saut en
longueur et que hier patrick abada
devait terminer deuxième du saut à la
perche
battu aux essais à 5 mètres 60 par le
jeune soviétique volkov mais la grande
vedette de ce week-end d'athlétisme à
turin fut incontestablement marita koch
absolument royal sur 400 coups après
avoir été la première femme à battre les
49 secondes
elle semble maintenant sur le chemin des
48 secondes quand elle domine série va
seul contre le chronomètre
elle réalise ici 48 secondes 60
centièmes améliorant de 29 centièmes son
record du monde 48 secondes 60 centièmes
un temps que beaucoup d'hommes environ
et elle n'a que 22 ans
confirmation au saut à la perche du
talent du junior soviétique constantin
volkov 5 mètre soixante meilleurs que
prévu et cela à son premier essai à
turin hier il n'a pas raté une seule
main patrick hamad a quant à lui devait
franchir cet auteur à son deuxième essai
au classement final double victoire
est-allemand cantons français 7e et
avant dernier chez les hommes il aurait
pu sans les contre-performances de la
première journée terminée plus près des
anglais et des italiens qui ne les
devance respectivement que de 11 points
et demi et 2 8 points mais il ne faut
pas se faire d'illusions septième au
plus haut niveau européen
l'athlétisme français est bien à sa
place allemand soviétique anglais
polonais sont pour l'instant hors
d'atteinte
el cordobès laitière l affiche à bayonne
dans leur trouver avec son style peu
académique et son dédain pour ne pas
dire son mépris des règles établies on a
pensé aux exagérations war aux excès
dans sa vie est si plein mais est ce fut
disent les connaisseurs du très grand
spectacle il est vrai que d'autres
connaisseurs vise ce ne fut que du grand
spectacle mais pas de l'art allez savoir
en tout cas le corps novès est là et on
serait tenté de dire
la tauromachie se révèle el cordobès le
fut l'anticonformiste à 43 ans revient
après huit années d'absence le public
est au rendez vous rendez vous d'un
spectacle peu implantant toxiques
on est venu voir manuel benitez el
cordobès foire des émotions et vibrato
disons le tout de suite on ne sera pas
déçu
la légende sera présente dans l'arène
quand mauvaise c'est qu'on l'attend et
ne néglige aucun temps de préparation
une séance de massage qui va durer plus
d'une demi heure mais à 43 ans homme
d'affaires riche alors tout cela pour
quoi
je suis très longue en italie il est
allé à tort ils empilent habitants qui
n'ont pas un tollé mais je vienne à sa
place et pourtant el cordobès avait fait
ses adieux aux arènes alors pourquoi
revient-il kctu despedida la route non
quand même ici l'on met l'accent sur le
cam arrêtés et ils se reposer pour être
en forme pour recommencer
mais huit ans pour être en forme c'est
très long quand tu as muse permettait
une forme en club où il argo toujours
est il qu'aujourd'hui n'a rien perdu de
son efficacité
le pas décidé il roule un peu des
épaules et va chercher le taureau baisse
on disait de vous cette le torero
courageuse et le torero un peu fou est
ce que vous êtes toujours ce torero et
valence
elles ont pourtant mené
renault dément formellement qu'il y ait
eu le moindre contact avec le pilote
autrichien niki lauda ancien champion du
monde des conducteurs pour qu'ils
entrent dans l'équipe renault sport les
rumeurs qui circulent qui roule à ce
propos sans fondement météo de mardi le
temps donc une étroite zone de nuages
avant d'entrer vert fera demain la
moitié du pays
ces renseignements me sont donnés par le
satellites meteosat de fabrication
française
cette baisse de température accompagnera
donc la zone de nuages à bonds dans le
temps sera chaud et parfois orageux
ailleurs le temps sera ensuite variable
avec des éclaircies devenant de plus en
plus belle une information de dernière
minute séisme à san francisco la ville a
été secoué aujourd'hui par le
tremblement de terre le plus violent que
san francisco et collective un an on ne
signale fort heureusement aucun blessé
il ya eu deux secousses à 30 seconde
d'intervalle lignes téléphoniques
coupées
métro arrêtée et fort heureusement il
n'y a eu aucun accident grave en tous
les cas on rappelle s d'occasions qu'en
1906 san francisco était presque
entièrement rasé par un tremblement de
terre particulièrement violent
aujourd'hui donc plus de peur que de mal
heureusement
à 23 heures hervé claude donnera les
dernières informations
n'oubliez pas demain antenne de midi et
à 20h c'était mon plaisir
nous nous retrouverons ici même on sera
merci
à